[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number
69 with cats and everything like that q
and a
segment so many cats so many cats many
queues
we have a couple of questions okay
that's not where we're starting though
no yeah oh doggie didn't get any cream
all right from episode 68
i remember it well we have uh
four questions from last week and then a
discord question and then
launching into this week's questions
should there be concerns about antibody
dependent enhancement with the coveted
vaccines
it seems like this possibility is being
overlooked by the general consensus of
doctors advocating for vaccination
uh say the beginning part of it again
should there be concerns about antibody
dependent enhancement
antibody dependent enhancement um i
cannot say
that i have any expertise with respect
to antibody dependent enhancement
do we know well i mean i feel like we've
talked about this maybe you're just
recognizing it in these terms like the
the idea of an autoimmune reaction
um as a result of being you know
being prompted to promote antibodies
precisely for
um for the spike protein
well i'm just concerned that i'm
overlooking some meaning of that term
that i uh okay don't
don't know so anyway i'm surprised by
this but okay i can't say
um but certainly autoimmune
uh autoimmunity is a concern um
there are other concerns i mean frankly
this is a complex system and it could
trigger
virtually any pathology cancers are a
possibility
i saw a paper i have not had a chance to
vet it but i saw a paper suggesting
the possibility of the triggering of
prion disease
yeah yeah me too but i didn't i didn't
spend enough time with it to when i
talked about today
right yeah so anyway yeah
all right what might severity of covid
vaccine injection side effects
[Music]
code vaccine injection site side effects
maybe
have to say about the recipient's immune
system
i'm 76 very healthy very fit very trim
but had 36 hours
36 plus hours of chills after the first
modernity jab
um i
don't i i i've been i've been waiting
for this analysis and i haven't seen it
and anecdotally what i'm hearing from
people um you know just
just anecdotally talking to a lot of
people who have had the first and
sometimes the second
jabs of both um is it seems to vary
widely whether or not people are having
or not having side effects reactions i
agree i heard the same
short term side effects yeah no idea
obviously we covered in a prior live
stream
uh some very severe side effects
including at least one fatal
case but in terms of correlation with
some of these comorbidities
um or you know specifically what it
might indicate about immune system
um you know we might predict that it
would
but i have not seen the analysis and so
it would be pure speculation
yeah yep does wearing a mask
increase the viral load on a person due
to the infectious stage increasing the
chances
of a severe outcome that's written
weirdly but i think the idea
is um if you're if you're if you're
keeping
all of the viral particles that you
would be spreading yourself
on you when you're out and given that as
we've talked about you know mostly
months ago at this point
the both the likelihood of getting it
and then the likelihood of a severe
outcome both being dose dependent sort
of density dependent of viral particles
might you if you are sick um
increase the chances of being more sick
if you're wearing a mask which you know
before before we even get into that um
if that were true
it would be yet another reason that
really um
when you're sick wearing a mask in
public is not the top thing that you
should be doing what you should be doing
is when you're sick you don't go out in
public like that's the thing that you
should be doing to protect
yourself um and everyone else
yeah i must say my initial instinct
based on
the you know the cartoons in the
textbook from which i learned
uh immunobiology is that this is not a
concern but actually
now that i think through it i can't rule
it out completely i would say
i would expect that this effect would
not be very large
but i can't say it's zero yep um i think
there are other things to worry about
too like you know again i don't think
this would be a huge impact but
to the extent that one of the effects
here is to compromise you with respect
to
the amount of oxygen that you have
available that a mask has an obvious
implication for that
that it decreases the oxygen exchange
at the mouth now it won't be very big
because most of what you
exhale uh is going to be
outside of the mast there's not a lot of
volume inside of the mask even including
what's inside your
mouth and nose but it will have some
impact on the total exchange
yeah no i agree i think um i don't think
this thing has been
pro i haven't seen it in sort of cartoon
textbook style illustrations but
i can't figure out why it might not be
true
yeah i mean i the reason i don't see it
as
likely to be a big effect is that myself
which is different from
not likely to be true but not likely to
be um highly explanatory
and whether or not people end up right
in fact my instinct
says it would be below detectable but
okay why um
because my guess is the number of
particles
that you exhale and then with the mask
the difference between the number of
particles that you exhale and they
disappear from you
versus particles that you then re-ingest
right or re-aspirate
is going to be small compared to the
number of particles that will be sitting
on the surfaces in your lungs for
example
as a result of the initial production
so my guess is that you are not
virus limited once you're sick the
limitation that decides how sick you are
is not
the number of viral particles that there
are plenty of viral particles like it's
not dose dependent from your own
production
because your body can your the virus can
presumably produce
sort of as much as it wants right well
then right exactly
but that said yep is it likely to be
true
that some covid patients are sometimes
infected by viruses that they otherwise
would have expelled and that it results
in some
piece of tissue that would not have
gotten infected getting infected
it's very hard to rule that out yeah i
agree
um final question from last week
brett and heather what should i be
considering to understand the
endocrinological implications of
so-called
top surgery on a young woman's long-term
health
thanks for what you do anger of my week
um and i it shouldn't matter much but
the person writing is at least using a
male name
um so you know i don't know if it's just
a
just a question it doesn't appear to be
um
well i don't know i don't know what that
means actually yeah i don't know what i
mean what that means
um
yeah i i don't have the like half hour
the relevant half hour litany at the tip
of my tongue here
uh but the fact is that that
healthy breasts are an important part of
a healthy woman's body
and they change throughout life um
they change with um menses they change
you know monthly with menses and they
change with pregnancy and then they
certainly change with lactation
um i don't know
you know what simply getting rid of them
early on
is going to do i know for instance this
is not this is not an answer but i feel
like there's something in
this thing i'm about to say that is that
is going to
that should have impact on the accurate
answer here which i which i don't have
which is that for instance um women
who um breastfeed less or never
in their lives are at higher risks of
um i think it's just breast cancers but
it may be actually other cancers as well
other so-called reproductive cancers as
well
and so uh you know what would simply
getting rid of those breasts presumably
before any breastfeeding happened
um due to that analysis i'm not sure if
it's just breast cancers
presumably it sort of takes care of the
problem but um
the fact is this is not just these
aren't just balloons pasted to women's
breasts you know these are integral
parts of the body uh that have
feedback and uh
we don't really know what all the
long-term effects are going to be
all right so i want to back the question
up a little bit okay um
hormone is a
molecule that triggers a physiological
reaction
at a distance right so it's very much
metabolically the same thing as a
neurotransmitter except over a long
distance
right the question really seems to be
are breasts producers of hormones that
trigger
other tissues i find that likely but i
don't know it to be the case
or are they simply receptors breasts are
certainly modified by hormonal
information
right so for example pregnancy triggers
changes in breasts that are presumably
at least partially mediated hormonally
but that doesn't mean
that they're generating hormones that
are triggering other parts of the body
though that seems
plausible to me yeah i and i feel like i
should know the answer that but i just
don't off the top of my head
right so anyway i think i think the
answer is going to rest largely on that
now with respect to the issue of why
not breastfeeding results in an increase
in the risk of cancer i believe this is
actually at least partially maybe
entirely a telomere phenomenon
the idea being that the that
breasts under ancestral circumstances
would have been
heavily utilized in the feeding of
babies and relatively early in a woman's
life
and that the excess reproductive
capacity of
the cells in the breast tissue
basically being programmed for the
ancestral load on breasts
constitutes extra cancer risk in the
modern environment especially if you do
something like
decide not to have children or use
formula
instead and therefore reduce wear and
tear or even i mean even
having kids later and breastfeeding and
having fewer kids like all of these are
actually understood
to have some increased be correlated
with some increased risk
of cancers and for those who are
longtime listeners to the podcast
the idea that even just having the same
number of kids but delaying it and then
breastfeeding them results in a residual
risk fits exactly the paradigm
that we see with respect to skin cancers
and sun damage
the idea being that early
mutations cause larger prototumors which
then
have a greater statistical risk of some
cell
in the prototumor getting a second
mutation that activates
telomerase and so that would be exactly
predicted by
by this model yup
all right um discord question for this
week
where um uh the the people participating
uh vote on their favorite question that
has been proposed for the week how do we
this is somewhat longer than usual
how do we deal with the denigration of
women who prefer to be housewives
my wife has spent nine years in
university to become an architect
only to realize a year after finishing
that no one told her it was acceptable
to be a homemaker her reaction was to
cry and tell me she feels that by doing
this she will not contribute to society
enough
this seems to be a negative in my humble
opinion that we are brainwashing young
girls with marxist ideas of everyone
being a good worker
rather than driving people towards their
ideals
um so i talked about um
you know the larger issue of choice
often a feminist based choice only
refers to abortion
but the larger issue of choice i think
it was in my conversation with
kelly j keane on biological women's hour
that um
that posted a week and a half or two ago
um which i which i recommend
um that you know we should we certainly
don't want to go regressive back to like
mad men era 1950s
this is what's expected like you know
like the obituary that i read
um in the last hour um and
we also don't want to
go sort of full um abandonment of
motherhood second wave
feminism um working outside the home
whether or not there are any good
options for you or you want to do it is
the only thing to choose both
both of those are are insufficient
as choices that women should be allowed
to make and you know frankly i heard a
story
similar to this um not not exactly this
um between um
well actually i'm not going to say who
it was but you know some some well-known
some well-known people who found
themselves in this very situation
and i have to say that unless it's a
unless it's a very different generation
i don't recognize it i just i don't
recognize the world
that um danette what is the language
um no one told them that it was
acceptable to be a homemaker
or uh brainwashing young girls with
marxist ideas everyone being a good
worker like i don't recognize either of
those things
at all from anything i've ever seen or
experienced
you know for me it was like you can be
anything you want
and um yeah i
love being a mother but i was i was
never driven i didn't play with dolls it
was just not it was
not the thing that was interesting to me
as
as a child to imagine that life for
myself later on
um even though if you had asked me i
probably would have said well sure i
expect so i don't know we'll see right
um
and there are also you know many girls
for whom
they think that that is the thing that
they want and then they discover some
passion and they discover that it's
actually not the thing that they want to
do later on and maybe they never do
become mothers and that also should be
legitimate
um so i guess i um i'm
a little recoiling and also resisting
the narrative built into this question
of um of this landscape of women as
workers and men as workers and everyone
just need to work because
i you know i think i think our economy
is forcing this on people but i don't
think this is coming from on high in any
way i think we're being forced
you know both both parents in uh double
parent homes are being forced to work
um because they can't pay the bills
otherwise even when
uh one of them would prefer not to be
working and that's a damn shame
like we should not have that be being
the case but
um you know if if you're spending a lot
of time in school
thinking and you know if your education
is any good at all
all of it should be about considering
why you're doing what you're doing why
you're there what is it you're hoping to
accomplish in the world and
um i'm saddened and
disheartened that you would get to the
end only at the end of it would you
realize that you actually had a choice
all along
i would also point out that at this
moment we are
facing a situation in which all of us
whose kids
are in school are now watching
a um a
pathogenic view on the universe being
inflicted on children and there's a
certain amount that you can do over
dinner each night
where you make them immune
to taking this on but increasingly
school is becoming less and less
valuable and
the role of a parent in
uh getting proper software into the
kid's head
is growing more more important and at
some point
you know the point is well you know is a
household in which one parent
takes on the role of making sure that
you know
the kids are uh well oriented to the
world
and keeps them away from the nonsense
you know is the
is that the the household of the future
and then the question is an economic one
how does such a household float
but i don't i mean i don't i don't think
that household
frankly um all else being equal
will produce children as um as
able to navigate all of the complexity
of the world
as if both of their parents are actually
doing parenting
and um and take a step back
from your hard-hitting 80-120 hours week
careers you know it's it's really hard
to make this argument to
you know a lot of people in a lot of
careers it's just it's you know the
world is not set up this way but
um frankly we did it
and um you know we were we were blessed
with a lot of things that were true
right um we both had we were both
college professors with a lot of
flexibility in our schedules and we
could
we could schedule things in advance such
that um you know when one of us was in
class the other one wasn't and such and
we had
um really a truly amazing on-campus day
care
situation where we could go part-time
such that you know for a few hours a day
um a few days a week when we both really
needed to be working
you know our kids could be there and be
socialized as well and we lived close
enough to campus that we were biking
back and forth we didn't need to touch
the car during an average week it's not
to say that we didn't get in the car but
the point is
commute time was zero or near to it yep
um yeah so i mean
everything about that situation was like
you know and and
we were both thrilled to be parents
and excited to be part of the raising of
the children
you know there was there was no sense
it's no one's favorite job to change
diapers but there was no sense that it
was your job or my job
it was our job because we had this kid
and
it needed to be changed and he wouldn't
be reasoned with just
no there is now i'm really pleased to
find but true but
but yeah there was no there's no
reasoning with the baby okay but then
the point is look we've got an economic
problem which is the two incomes are
necessary
to raise a family we've got a school is
going crazy
and therefore you know it's not obvious
that
the wiring of children should ever have
been offloaded as far as it was
it's not obvious that that was a good
idea yeah but nonetheless
the uh insanity of the moment is
revealing
you know that you know are all the
reasonable kids going to be
kids whose parents rescued them from a
educational system
in free fall right i mean that that
strikes me as plausible
well most and most parents can't afford
to so the question is what will happen
and then maybe that
interfaces with covet in a weird way in
the sense that the world has just
discovered that a lot of people i
thought that's what you were talking
about
was the educational free fall
breastfelting from covet now you're
talking about all the wokeness
the madness i mean my basic sense is the
purpose of school
is primarily to enhance the capacity of
the mind and effectively
it is now doing the opposite it's
creating mind damage
and to the extent that school is going
to mind damage your kids
people are going to catch on that they
actually
for the moment are not required to
participate in that process
and you know i think lots of things are
possible for one thing
there's got to be a mechanism for a
group of parents who all simultaneously
reach this realization
to opt their kids out together and then
you know those kids of course are going
to be
better armed for the future than anybody
else so you know
when are we going to see this revolution
it seems like it's ready to dawn
it yeah it sure is i'm reminded this is
an anecdote that may not seem relevant
but i'm reminded
just you know speaking to how silly
education has gotten
and this is a number of years ago but
when um when we did do our study abroad
together in 2016
so our boys would have been 11 and 9
turning 12 and 10 at the end of that
field season um our older son zach who
is now the producer of the dark horse
podcast
and an 11th grader
was in middle school and we
were taking them out of school for 11
weeks to do study abroad with us you
know they were effectively
um junior members of the you know
upper level undergraduate program
in science and philosophy of science and
animal behavior and ecology and
anthropology and
literature in you all of these things
that we were studying and
um one of zack's teachers in fact his
geography teachers i remember it could
not actually see what the educational
value
of such a trip would be and so insisted
that he work
on his project which was hey zach what
country were you working on
uh i think i actually decided to work on
madagascar
okay so zach had chosen to work on
madagascar for his geography project
because
i had worked on madagascar and i've
written a book about madagascar and he
had read it
but his teacher while we were in ecuador
insisted that zach be working on a
project on
madagascar which is ridiculous
and really points to the idea that you
know teachers are like it's not
education unless i crafted it and told
you to do it anything that happens
outside of what i told you to do must
not be learning and
um i wish you wouldn't do that on my
time and so you know meanwhile
we're giving these children a you know a
world-class college level education
right i mean nothing educates a kid
quite as much as being jaguar bait
i mean that's just that sharpens the
mind right there yep yep
yep absolutely okay um next question how
about
i am not totally sure what this means
i'm gonna read it
uh they're right there yes they are okay
does intelligence and conscience
circumvent the human's ability to mutate
for adaptation
due to our ability to carry most
genotypes and phenotypes
that are evolutionarily a disadvantage
into the future
would this mean human evolution would be
slowed and more diverse
yeah that's that's a lot of words and so
you know i put at the top here because
it came in with a with a
big donation so i'm wondering if you
don't i just i think there's a lot of
words
that don't the term conscience is it
supposed to be consciousness
it might be does that make does that
make it make sense to you
well i would at least get it to one
theme um not sure
let's say that in the neighborhood
we have um the
[Music]
genome having offloaded a tremendous
amount of the work
of um storing and transmitting and
generating adaptations
to the software layer that includes
things like consciousness
it also includes conscience although i
just don't see
how it's relevant here and so you would
expect there to be
a viscosity component that is to say a
resistance to adaptation you don't want
the propensity to change to be so great
that adaptations don't stick and that
momentary changes cause the breakdown
you know for example it may take
generations to learn how to produce a
proper canoe out of
trees that are locally available to you
and the
knowledge to create canoes may vanish
in a single generation if nobody makes
one
so anyway there you would imagine that
you would have a viscosity
term and a propensity to change term and
that there would be tension between them
and that different environments would
select for different amounts
but the amount the degree of willingness
to change ought to be
adaptively variable in and of itself and
you know we have analogs for all of this
in the genetic space too
but it's much uh much more rapid in the
in the
software space
uh any to you brett any thoughts or
revelations about social media
influence after your talk with tristan
any thoughts at all so many thoughts um
yeah boy unfortunately unfortunately i
haven't listened to the conversation yet
yeah and it's been a little bit since uh
you know we went through
um we've been through an ice storm since
i started a power outage
and uh anyway i think that there is
a very important conversation that we
need to be having more generally
about the fact of the ai apocalypse
having arrived on our doorstep without
us noticing because it didn't look like
we were led to fear we were led to fear
robots
it turned out it was algorithms and
what's more it's not even algorithms
it's cyborgs
right so you've got algorithms
that are not intelligent
they evolve but they're crude
but then you have intelligent humans
sitting there giving the algorithms what
they don't
themselves possess and that combination
is resulting
in an environment in which things are
evolving rapidly and
have escaped our control and what part
of that are you calling cyborg
well i'm arguing that you've got a
silicon
part right the algorithms are running on
silicon
and then you've got imagine that the
silicon is lacking
human creativity right and that we
imagine oh
someday computers will be smart enough
to have it oh no they do have it it's
sitting in a chair
right in front of the silicon and i mean
i i hear you i mean i think your point
about
the ai you know the ai apocalypse
arrived it didn't look like robots that
look like algorithms a point you've been
making for a while
tristan has not been making that point
exactly but he's obviously been in this
space for a long time
is critical um i resist the idea of what
you've just described as cyborg because
you know just like having these two
pieces that both
exist absent um the other you know
cyborg suggests a kind of a shared fate
uh that uh at least yet
we don't have well okay you resist i
would point out your resistance is
useless
sure uh of course you would no doubt
your child you just ask your computer
yeah
but in any case we're done here in any
case
i think the point is look if we take the
analogy we expected robots
right cyborgs are part living
part robot fused together you know uh
but the fuse thing is the part that i
think right but my point is once you
step into the software layer what does
the fusion look like
software of computers or software of
humans both okay
if the point is we were expecting a
hardware ai apocalypse
instead what we got is a software ai
apocalypse and the cyborgs look like a
person staring into a screen rather than
a person with uh robot parts grafted
onto them
okay and the point software cyborg is
not heavy where cyborg so that's that's
the distinction that i was not
getting from what you were saying okay
yeah all right okay i love it
awesome this is the future i want
that i know not to be true
thanks for oh this is just a a nice
comment thanks for these very public
services that you're providing i have
met some amazing folks
and made some wonderful new friends
thanks the dark horse discord server
my life is greatly enriched by your
podcasting community thank you that is
awesome
please let us know the first couple
that forms on the discord server and
then
alert us when you're your firstborn
emerges
what that was a lot of crickets all at
once
um yeah you know
it raises we've not talked about this
there is a beautiful structure
on our commute to work at evergreen
between our house
like our commute is from the bedroom
right okay not this commute but the
prior commute which was slightly longer
and went through that
barely it was it was the world's best
commute actually because it was an
actual commute
and it was like um less than a mile
door-to-door of single track biking
three quarters of a mile single track
biking through the evergreen forest it
was pretty cool
and there was the japanese gate which
was a beautifully crafted
wooden structure and
arbor i guess that one just went right
the trail went right under it and the
the mythology was that it had been
constructed
by people who were hoping that a child
would be conceived under the gate who
would then
eventually enroll in and graduate from
evergreen oh yes that's right so so i
was
i i am excited for the
discord server to be creating community
and for people to be
uh meeting each other through that that
was not the nature of the crickets it
was the
um your tendency to decide to announce
that you want to hear from people in
some way and to just then
kind of back away and let the fallout
fall no no no everywhere else but
well first of all if people are going to
be meeting in large numbers
and pairing up and producing children i
do think we want to hear about it even
if it creates some
email traffic but i think that's liable
to be a rare enough event that the extra
the extra correspondence will not be
overwhelming it's not
it's not about everyone
it's you really again you really don't
know the effect that you have in the
world in many regards
no but i'm aware of that my my level of
self-awareness
yes on that front is pretty high it is i
know this
did your brain evolve to cover our needs
did our brain
that was probably not did your brain
love to cover our needs and if not what
the hell is it doing yeah
nobody knows um did our brain oh boy
did our brain involved to cover our
needs or was it always
more capable if you took an infant from
ancient realm and raised it in 2021
would they have any issues
how far back were we capable of today's
intellectual demand okay i got this
yeah let me just do the easy part at the
end first
all right all right because you'll bury
it
but so prob at least 200 000 years
i think back um you took
you took any of those babies and you
moved them into a modern environment
give them a shave and some
some yeah well no the babies don't need
shaves you
you take babies from any of those times
and you move them into modern times and
they should be just fine so ancient rome
no problem at all
certainly agriculture no problem at all
it may be that something else is
happening
in like the 50 000 to 200 000 year range
but
it seems that we were what
anthropologists call anatomically modern
humans by 200 000 years ago which means
that given how much of
us is software if you just pluck out
that baby as soon as they're born from
whatever the environment is
and move them into a modern um
child-rearing environment
um they'll they'll pass as a modern kid
i am surprised at you this is magical
thinking
oh boy if you were to take a child from
the roman empire or any other point in
that
200 000 years and trans transport them
to modernity right at the beginning yeah
yeah
um they'd be wildly [ __ ] up just like
the rest of us
i mean right you're absolutely right
that was magical thinking why do i think
an older baby right would do better now
why would they do
any better they wouldn't no they would
have exactly
this level of confusion i stand accused
and guilty yeah they wouldn't know what
to eat
they wouldn't know went to sleep any of
that stuff yeah
um so anyway hopefully you gleaned in
that exchange
the answer to your question which is um
oh do you actually disagree with
anything i said other than
for comedic purposes only yeah okay yeah
all right
um so yes the child would have exactly
the same capacities and you could
integrate them into modernity and they'd
be just fine
um the other part of the question though
was does
this did our brain evolve to cover our
needs or was it always
more capable okay yeah that's that's
yeah that's more complicated um in some
ways it's super simple
right there's no way for the capacity to
evolve ahead of the needs right it is
the needs because the brain
is so expensive both to build it is
expensive to possess
it puts one at great risk it puts one's
mother at great risk during
birth it's expensive to run it's
expensive to run in fact the most
expensive organ
uh to run all of these things mean that
the pressure to have less of it
is very strong and so the point is what
drives us to have more
brain and more mind running on that
brain
is the fact that it enhances our fitness
and that doesn't mean
that every individual is being paid back
for the full capacity of their brain but
what it means is that on average
members of the species are being paid
back above the level of those costs
which are major so
yep there's uh there's no excess
capacity
even though most people behave as if
they are not using their minds right
um okay next question i just tried
plugging in the
recommended url and my computer is going
really slowly so i can't make sure this
is the right one
uh this is mostly just a comment hi
really appreciate you two for such great
sense making
see ifmeta ivmmeta.com for real-time
analysis
of uh 42 if ivermectin efficacy studies
for cobot19
so that sounds like a useful site um i
wish it was
yeah it just stalled out um uh
thanks and keep the good stuff coming
matt in the uk no punchline as to
whether or not they reflect
the success well i imagine that if
there's an actual
site then they're
i don't know yeah it's not coming up
anyway uh hopefully that's just a
problem on our end at the moment and not
a problem with this
um with this url
any top any tops any tips
do any tips that's it that's the
question you know i've
got a few pens around here that are
missing them so presumably they're
somewhere
yeah any tips for self-studying [ __ ]
free liberal arts
i'm a computer nerd looking to broaden
my horizon
um it's increasingly hard i mean i
all of all of the older fields have
value if they are still done
with you know the the sort of analytical
and creative tools
um that made them valuable in the first
place i
think we have to back up by to figure
out what they mean by liberal arts
before
we know whether or not the tools are
good or not
um because certainly i mean my take on
the liberal arts the the liberal arts
that i would defend
are the um the pursuit
of tools irrespective
of their applicability to work
yes and so there are tools which are
going to be harder to acquire though not
impossible you can even source good
history on youtube there are some very
interesting channels
but the number of tools that you have to
train your mind to do
things logically speaking you know
get yourself an arduino kit
and start playing around with it and
you'll discover that you can actually
build uh logic
gates and also this is a computer nerd
looking to broaden his horizon
okay true but okay but well i don't
think an arduino kit
qualifies sorry as broadening the
horizon for a computer nerd who's
looking for
[ __ ] free liberal arts well it
depends i mean
i really don't know it right but like
the one of the programs we did just to
provide background here
uh evolution of the human condition
right a freshman
all level program with a bias towards
freshmen first-year students two-quarter
program that we did the year before we
did our year-long
study program that included 11 weeks in
ecuador so this would have been
winter spring 2015.
um evolution the human condition we read
some amazing books we went deep on
things like food and sex and
relationship and like it was really in
some ways some of the foundations of
what we've
what is in the book that we've written
and um
and we did learn a skill projects and
everyone had to you know figure out how
to actually learn how to do something in
the world
two different times two different
quarters
and there were weekly physical computing
workshops
and when you first proposed this i was
like what the hell are we doing with
physical computing workshops in
a program called evolution the human
condition where you know i'm having them
read literature and philosophy and
science and
you know like how are we going to
justify this so
here now now with that setup i ended up
compelled
not only did we do it but you did it and
actually zach and you ran this together
yep
um when he was he would have been 11. um
and
uh yeah some students never got into it
um but a lot of people
were actually surprised at how much it
brought to the
the learning environment i mean look
you're going to live in a world
of machines and they can all be black
boxes or you can have some idea what
might be inside of them
and yes you know a computer is so
miniaturized and has so many
uh effectively switches inside of it
that you know it is in some ways very
different but um there's
there's all the difference in the world
between those of us who are relegated to
exchanging information with a machine
by talking to it in the language that it
knows versus
those who can you know construct uh you
know
an and gate and or gate etc um
so it's not obvious to me that somebody
who is
uh you know maybe a computer science
nerd would definitely have those skills
i don't know but even if we take that
off the table
and we say physical computing may not be
the thing that broadens your horizons
but there are dozens
hundreds of things that you can learn
now from youtube far
better than you would be able to learn
them from a book
and you want my personal take
the most interesting genre
of um instructional videos on youtube
are the ones that do not have any
instructions in which you watch
somebody who knows how to do something
do it
and then you work backwards you infer
what they must be doing and why it works
and if you
were to try to accomplish any of these
things you would discover all of the
stuff that was
uh integral to these processes and
anyway so i have a i have a
totally different type of answer which i
think you'll also
be into and i know you will be um i
don't tend to spend time on youtube
videos i just i'm not
drawn to spending any more time on
screens than i have to
um which is already a lot of time uh
so self-studying [ __ ] free liberal
arts
um i would say travel and
the way that i and the thing that i do
that i think you you don't really is i
tend to load myself
up in advance of going someplace either
new or where i've been before
um with literature from that place um in
translation because my
foreign language skills are good enough
to get me through places but not to
enjoy the literature of them
um learning um i will tend to do
i will tend to try to self-educate in
the pre-history of the place in advance
and then make sure to visit whatever
sites are possible to
to explore um the you know earlier
people
than the ones who are currently living
in a place
and then i mean the other big thing
which is not you know i don't it doesn't
exactly qualifies liberal arts but
just the cuisine right the you know the
exploring uh the local food of a place
and you know really
really going and eating you know where
the locals eat
also regardless almost regardless of how
bad your language skills are
you will you will end up engaging if you
in any way are interested in doing so
with the local people and so
end up learning about about things that
you never would have learned and i'm
thinking actually
um when we were in turkey so we were we
were in turkey for our honeymoon in 1998
and we were in cappadocia on the vast
anatolian plane
um in this it's just a amazing place
with like
you know like stratified layers of
cities on top of one another in these
caves
and i don't even remember exactly how it
happened something like this happened a
few times so at one point we're sitting
outside and we're just approached
um by a local man who ended up
showing us you know just showing us
around for the day
and we ended up sharing um a meal
on a you know on a carpet with his
family outside somewhere
during the apricot harvest with like all
these apricots drying on the roofs
um and you know just if that's on
education i don't know what is and yes
it's also travel and adventure and
exploration and all of this but
you know the the two of us and the you
know i feel like it was probably four
five six people in his family with whom
we ended up sharing this meal
um all ended up with an experience that
we wouldn't have had
we not just simply been in that place us
were
we were open he was open um we were able
to
you know connect and and so explore and
you know our turkish is far worse than
our spanish or our french so
um i think he probably had some english
if i remember correctly this is many
many years ago but
um you know that that's the sort of
experience
that um is what learning liberal arts in
the classroom is supposed to open up for
you
yeah it's almost like earth is the
ultimate liberal arts education for
earthlings
yeah yeah yeah
since you live with a big group of cats
i assume your inner catologist is
tempted to make observations and
hypotheses about their behavior
and they about us can you share some of
them p.s the cats may share the same
about you if they wish
really you already always jump at the
punchline dude
i mean i find that kind of cool yeah
that is almost exactly what i said and i
sure hadn't seen it no you hadn't i
hadn't um
yeah so much right so much so what
there's i don't know we could come up
with a few things off the top of our
heads the one the one thing when i saw
that that i thought
that i had been surprised at when i
noticed this and this is not from our
current crew of cats
um
uh actually actually one of the cats
tesla
um who was our it was our black cat our
eldest cat who will be 10 this year
um named after the dude not the car no
the dude not the car
um when we had still had
when we do still have him and um and
pico and crenshaw
who were named after the los angeles
streets obviously
um they had
a hierarchy so i'm always fascinated by
the hierarchies the cat set up
and two things about their hierarchy
were not as i would have expected if i
had been watching say wild baboons or
something
one of which was they seem to have
different hierarchies for different
situations
so like displacement moves on the couch
or on someone's lap a different cat
would have
different priority would be able to
display someone whereas at the food dish
and i can't even remember at this point
probably crenshaw always had primacy at
the food dish
and one of the other two younger guys
had primacy
on laps but also in each of these
hierarchies where you could actually
watch it it was circular it wasn't
linear
and you know almost all of the work on
territoriality and hierarchy and
dominance hierarchies
is well one is that you've got separate
male and female hierarchies where you've
got
a social situation such that you've got
multiple of both sexes
but they're almost always described as
linear and sometimes a little bit
recursive or like you inherit your
mother's
mothers
and so you can you can jump the line um
but if we had three cats
you know a might be dominant to b b
dominant to c and c dominant to a which
sounds like it's not possible but um
it kind of was all right uh
the hypothesis i can't get past which
actually puts me in a tense situation
with other members of my family is that
i believe
the cats don't know their names
um and everyone else in my family
is of the belief without the ability to
demonstrate it that they uh
react that they respond to their names
in some way that indicates recognition
i believe that one of our cats has no
understanding that names exist
and that one of our cats does know his
name
and that the third cat the the jury is
somewhat out on that yes i believe
that no domestic cat knows their name
and the domestic cat owners
would be shocked furthermore you think
that our dog knows the cat's names
yeah oh yeah the dog knows a lot the
ty's up there no the dog
i don't know where the dog is going but
um yeah
the dog never calls the cats by name but
she knows them and she knows her own
name but
yeah no this this this we're in
agreement on yes
that's all you got okay okay we should
do a cat episode at some point we could
we could do that yeah
in dan crenshaw's podcast you came to
the conclusion that you share the same
worldview though liberal versus
conservative
why are more people not coming to the
same conclusions about world as you are
that is to say why is it only thousands
of people why not millions
um yeah this is uh the question of the
moment yeah i think
this is um the result of some very bad
possibly cynically triggered dynamics
that have caused people not to realize
how much we have in common
i would also say there might be some
cognitive biases
built in ones that contribute to it
where we tend to focus
on those things that
are different and therefore um
you know as those differences grow small
you are still nonetheless
preoccupied with them yeah but yes it's
amazing when you travel across
uh political divisions how frequently
you realize that actually there's just a
tremendous amount that we hold in common
and then you know there are the things
in which we differ i'm sure
that uh dan and i would differ
on um how fair society
is and how
worthwhile the risks of trying to make
it fairer
are right those are pretty reliable
differences between
a liberal such as me and a conservative
such as dan
um but what we wouldn't tend to disagree
on is
whether we want a fair world
right so sort of picking up on that i
just moved it
up the queue here we've got this
question
i've observed a potential language
barrier between the left and the right
put simply the right tend to use markets
and capitalism as broad synonyms for
free association and voluntary
interaction absent coercion
whereas the left tend to use those words
in the more narrow sense of financial
transactions
specifically those that result in profit
making such as corporations or employers
and often ones they dislike
what are your thoughts so i think you
should riff on this but one thing
one thing that i really like about this
framing which i hadn't i hadn't
thought of before is that if it's if
it's accurate
it sort of points to um these these
latin terms from phylogenetic
systematics where you're talking about a
clade like monkeys
and you could talk about in the narrow
sense of i just mean these you know this
this meaning of the word monkeys or the
the larger sense so sensu strykto is the
narrow sense and zulato is the broad
sense
and it seems like the question seems to
suggest that
on the right the terms markets and
capitalism are used since
ulato and then the left tends to use
them sen sustricto and point to very
particular
problems with their instantiation yeah
although
increasingly i i sort of see
a kind of yin yang
division where the right is sort of
obsessed with the good things about them
and the left is obsessed with the bad
things about them and the conversation
that we need to have is the
yeah actually how could we leverage the
good part and hedge out the
you know reduce the the downside so do
you not agree with this framing then
because this framing is there's like a
there's a there's a
bigger view you know call let's call it
censulato since restrictor or call it
like thirty thousand foot view versus
i don't know ten foot view well i mean i
think you know it's a question of
where to stand to see it and there is
does it have a positive or negative
valence conservatives will tend to see
these things as positive
liberals will tend to see it as negative
um i almost never get a good definition
when i ask well what exactly is it that
you see is positive or negative
but so i think you're not answering the
question at least as i see it and as i
just tried to reframe it to you
i feel like you are saying you don't
agree with this framing that this
framing is
that people on the right are are having
this like this broad
this broad definition of markets
capitalism and markets and the people on
the left have a narrower
version and you're actually i think
saying people on the left have a narrow
version that's the negative one and
people on the right have a
similarly narrow version and it's the
positive one and no one is actually
taking the big view
well i think the point is it's not a
coherent big view
right i do think there is something
conservative sort of see
capitalism as that vibrant thing that
happens around
the you know the creation of wealth yeah
and you know that involves a lot of
freedom freedom to innovate freedom to
associate all those things
yeah um and the answer is well no we've
got to narrow down
what we're talking about and the point
is that
thing that happens in and around the
creation of wealth
is um marvelous and a [ __ ] disaster
simultaneously and the problem is that
we don't do
any we have there's no attempt to
separate out what the market
is actually good for and what it's
appalling at for example
insurance right the market cannot
deliver insurance
because the way you get profitable is to
figure out how to insure people who need
it least
right that's the go-to move yeah right
how to complicate the
claims process so that people who are
entitled to be reimbursed
often don't get reimbursed these are
just the go-to moves you weren't on the
phone with insurance people this week
how'd you guess oh my god oh my god what
a disaster i have to say
i lost my cool on yeah you never do that
i never do that but um and then i
responded by losing my cool the same
people
yeah it's amazing and you know the
trouble the reason i don't lose my cool
on the phone
is that i know that the person i'm
talking to is not the person who created
the stupid system there's somebody
trying to do their job but in this case
it was so
maddening to deal with a process that
was deliberately complicated
um that it was very hard to just keep a
lid on it
in any case the point is look if you
hand
the job of insuring people to the market
and then you say well let's see how the
market solves the problem the market
causes the problem yeah right there are
lots of other things you can do where
the market will solve the problem and
there is a division where we can say hey
let's not hand the jobs to the market
that it sucks at
right do we need more extreme
pornography i don't think so that's not
good for humanity
right the market will do that it will
keep doing it it'll get more and more
extreme i mean
you think this is extreme wait till you
see 2024
right that's coming sorry about that but
the point is look the magic of the
market we don't have a substitute for it
the horror of the market
um we could do without yeah and a proper
attempt to
relegate these things to the right quad
the right category
uh is an essential feature of i think
growing up and so
um i'm i'm looking at you conservatives
and liberals
get with the program all right let's get
just a few more of these before we go to
the next all right the
next uh the idea that you need a blank
and a group
seems like it flies in the face of our
ability to empathize across identities
reinforcing the very bigotry it seeks to
oppose truth doesn't stop being
uh truth doesn't stop being truth based
on who speaks it
it's just a comment but a blank in a
group i don't quite get it
a woman a black guy a trans guy i see
whatever yeah
people and so i agree with this
absolutely
people can mitigate their high risk so
this is a question about
comorbidities encode people can mitigate
their high risk by going on a ketogenic
diet
because nearly all the comorbidities
have insulin resistance as their cause
lowering blood sugar
lowers insulin increasing sensitivity
yeah
i think that's right we've talked about
that here
with in the past and i can't remember
exactly what the context was but
um yes
yes um
the way i see it is what did 90s kids
have anything to do with jim crow laws
or systemic racism
nothing yet it just seems as if our
generation is entering the workforce we
are being punished the most
it's total bs
um well it's total bs
it's partial bs there is something to be
frustrated about
and the problem is what it is is not
clear and so what we get is the
frustration
and then things like
this phenomenon where any accusation
is required to be supported which
results in the
fanciful idea that what has what is
going wrong that is causing things to be
unfair
is rampant white supremacy uh or bigotry
or any of these things
and it's of course not only incorrect
and resulting in the demonization of
people who haven't done anything wrong
but it is also preventing a proper
inquiry into what did go wrong
and so anyway it's not like we weren't
getting better but
um you know there's a tremendous amount
of room for
improvement and we're not going to get
there if we're going to
hunt witches instead that's right and i
say that
speaking as a witch or at least someone
who has been accused of witchcraft
on more than one occasion this week
really um yeah this uh
yeah i i maybe maybe i did not fully
recount the experience but um
in this conversation uh the uh the coup
on
clubhouse um i
i i was asked to say something about who
i was before i was interrogated about
whether i was a white supremacist and a
transphobe and there was one other thing
but i've forgotten what it was
fascist no sexist
no uh wasn't those things
right but um i said i was an
evolutionary biologist
oh that's just as bad which immediately
triggered one of the people
interrogating me to say oh you mean a
eugenicist oh my god
i know wow wow
now i once taught with an anthropologist
who seemed to complete those two things
just the same way actually
it's an amazing amazing thing wow
yep you know who was an evolutionary
biologist
huey p newton yes he was i find it
unlikely that he was eugenicist at least
not a white supremacist eugenicist
right i mean that just very little that
he did in his life would seem to support
that subsistence right
it's it's an extraordinary claim um
so anyway yeah that happened we are
academic siblings of assort
with uep newton yes we are yeah even
though we didn't get our phds from bob
tibbers but we were his undergraduate
students
and huey p newton earned his phd in
evolutionary biology from
the esteemed bob trivers from troopers
was his
advisor nah so now super chat questions
from this hour biologists
just biologists biologists speak of
evolution as a quasi-intelligent agent
than disclaimed purpose upsetting
philosophical rigor
can you articulate a proper rigorous
understanding of biological purpose
yeah i'm glad you understand the
question because i know
i think i get it um this person
um i'm going to presume this person is a
he
according to the name yes okay good um
he is alleging
in some ways correctly that we
evolutionists speak
as if evolution has a purpose
now we do that shorthand that we tend to
use
okay well no actually i will argue that
there are two purposes to be recovered
one is the shorthand right where if we
say
that a walnut tree puts uh
toxins into the soil to reduce
competition
yeah right what we mean is that walnut
trees
that have put things in the soil that
happen to disrupt the physiology of
other plants tend to out-compete those
that didn't by virtue of the fact that
they suffered less competition
but that's very common two weeks into
any academic program you're like okay
i'm going to start using fewer words now
anytime you want me to use the full
complement i'll do it but it gets old
yeah and in fact dawkins
in the salvation does this beautifully
what he says is i'm going to talk in
shorthand
and the important thing is that for any
place where i've talked in shorthand it
should be possible to go back and
recover the long hand
okay so there is no purpose he does that
brilliantly right so anyway
that's the basic rubric don't let the
fact that we talk with
purpose um throw you
right uh but then there's the other
point where there
is purpose it is not that evolution has
a purpose but i would argue i have
argued
that we get very confused because we
group
biology psychology
and medicine
together with chemistry and
physics right as sciences and what
unites them
is the method that we use to study them
that's why they are sciences
but what divides them is the fact
that biology psychology medicine
engineering are all places where purpose
is essential to understand what's going
on
and if you attempt to look at chemistry
or physics through the lens of purpose
you'll mess it up
right so the point is look it is natural
and in fact it's
it is essential if you want to
understand squirrel behavior
that you imagine that the squirrel is
trying to accomplish something and that
we say that that thing that the squirrel
is trying to accomplish
is ultimately recovered as something we
would call fitness and we can debate
what fitness is is it the same thing as
reproduction no it shouldn't be the same
thing as reproduction but it's closely
aligned with it
right the purpose the squirrel is
fulfilling is to enhance fitness
if we say that a neutrino
has passed through the earth rather than
interacting with any of the particles
here did it succeed in passing through
the earth did it
fail to interact with something that's
the wrong metric
it just simply didn't right so purpose
is important to understanding biology
which is not the same thing as saying
that evolution
has a purpose evolution is a process
that naturally unfolds it creates
creatures with purpose
very good thank you uh this is from echo
and therefore an excellent question
except it's like eight questions
um so you ready yep are moles
correlated to higher risk of any cancer
lower
how are balls inherited does the number
of moles and parents at time of
conception correlate with the
offspring's telomere length
did dad mult do do dad's moles correlate
more
so we talked about moles last week i
think and in fact this is not the only
mole question this week either
um but you want to so we did we did just
do moles a little bit is there an
organization in the mall
questions terrible
seven people caught the joke and they
are currently groaning on the floor no
i'd like that one
um yeah this is tough some of this we
just can't answer because we don't know
because we don't know
not because we refuse right that's one
answer
but um the number of moles and parents
at time of conception correlate with
offspring's telomere length
we don't know that right i think we do
not know that and do dad's moles
correlate more we therefore wouldn't
know that because it's downstream of the
first
heroines inherited yeah moles aren't
really inherited yeah
propensity for moles can be inherited so
for example if you
um well there's lots of stuff going on
here but
for example here's some things i think
we think we know
um one that males will produce
offspring with longer telomeres the
later in life they are conceived the
later in the father's life that they are
conceived
they are obviously conceived right at
the beginning of the child's life
um he was born six years old
okay so difficult birthdays
okay i'm over it um so telomere length
varies
telomere length that is uh inherited
will vary with the age of the father
um fathers will also vary between them
in terms of their tumor lengths right
controlling for age
right the size of a mole
should correlate with the telomere
length of the father
it should correlate uh
so so all moles on a person should
come to be the same size no no no no
because for one thing
across the father telomere lengths will
vary by tissue
okay and within a tissue they will vary
by
uh both position of the tissue and
damage but skin
so telomere length is also going to vary
across the skin right because moles are
only
moles aren't being generated from kidney
tissue right they will also
vary presumably by when in the lifetime
they were triggered there yes so the
younger that was triggered the larger
they will be
but the number of moles will also
presumably be
a a consequence of
the resistance to mutation so a
dark-skinned
parent will presumably produce fewer
moles because they will have less
on average interaction with uv rays that
will cause
mutation it will also vary with exposure
and so anyway there's a lot of factors
that contribute
and you know as with the topic we were
talking about in the first
hour you know you could unpack what is
the contribution of each of these things
to the number of moles the size of moles
the heritability of moles
etc but as for what the patterns are
i don't know yup
boy did the ontological phenomenological
distinction exist
or was it experienced before mankind was
self-aware
well oh you got it no oh
damn i don't at all i don't i never
remember
this is just not a part of philosophy
that i remain
fluent in after i'm not thinking about
it so
um i mean there's there's also just so
many different ways to parse
the universe that um a lot of them are
not
what we happened to traffic in what was
the question
did it precede what
did the ontological phenomenological
distinction exist
or was it experienced before mankind was
self-aware
um i don't think it can have
i mean doesn't this require
self-awareness
maybe i'm missing what the distinction
in question is supposed to be
yeah i'm i don't i don't know
i i'm not at the moment familiar enough
uh
with okay with what the how the terms
are used
uh to answer it well
um mama heather and papa brett did the
kids go by the last name
weinstein heinstein love the podcast
keep it up
whining obviously they're the whinings
um they're weinsteins they're weinsteins
they're weinsteins you know it works it
um
i don't know what our ancestors were
doing that resulted in that last name
something in the neighborhood of wine
production
or consumption i don't know
yeah yeah i know there and boy we
we really had very little discussion
about either
what would happen with names when we got
married or what would happen with names
when
we had kids yeah i think it was sort of
in the ethos that
um i was not going to change my name
because
i was we were now signing up together
for life
and because of
you know because we are in a patrilineal
rather than matrilineal society it is
confusing
it is a little bit confusing for us all
not to have the same four names but my
individual agency trumped that
and um i didn't see then i didn't feel
the need
to pass on my um frankly somewhat
ridiculous last name
to our children and thus potentially
confuse paternity as well
i mean that's i mean really i guess the
evolutionary question is like i was
never
there was never any uncertainty of
maternity in
in either of her children's case i never
i never doubted for a moment
it was really hard to wonder the
pregnancy being what it is
right it's just too hard to fake for one
time yeah um
yeah yeah um and while i never had any
uncertainty in paternity apparently
everyone else had had had that uh as the
little bit in their evolutionary brains
you're not talking about in our case
you're just talking about the
commonality
no i'm just saying theoretically no one
else can know yeah
no one else can know for sure except for
genetic testing which does allow you to
know but
nonetheless i think this is a perfect
actual perfect case for
chesterton's fence and how to wield it
with care because
in this case there was a very good
reason for you to keep your name
which was that um this was not
a traditional relationship where you
were um you know where our identities
were fused your identity was
in the world doing work just like mine
so
having your name um made perfect sense
from the point of view of what to do
with the kids it's not like
any of the solutions that people have
put together in modernity solve the
problem
right they all confuse one thing they
trade one thing for another
and so we went with the traditional um
rubric uh for the kids
yeah and it doesn't feel in any way um
regressive or disappearing of
you know of my role in their in their
lives
yeah yeah yeah yeah um
yeah nor did we um stick them with
haying as middle names
right yeah now we give them
pronounceable um
pronounceable uh
what's the word for the first initials
initials
um impacted molars near and
farsightedness morning sickness
seem maladaptive are there any similar
widespread conditions found in nature
symptoms of poor modern diet or
environment less fit gene pool
ps opening a freezer warms the room
yes it does yes it does so that's a
reference too um
last week taco your joke about opening
three freezers cools down texas
well i was imagining freezers on the
border
with i don't know
oklahoma no um so
almost rescued it nope no
no not bad given the time pressure i
guess
you did have a week i didn't know this
was going to come up no you didn't
okay so um great question with one
caveat
um the three examples here of things
that seem
adaptive impacted roller rollers
it's been a long week it's it has
impacted molars
near and far sightedness um
[Music]
well and then one of morning sickness
wait wait wait
um near and far sightedness the thing
that happens in middle age the
presbyopia that happens to everyone in
middle age
seems to be
neither an adaptation nor a male
adaptation it seems to be
a it seems to be a senescent
effect of muscle
activation ability of the extrinsic eye
muscles around the
orbits all right i'm going to go a
little i don't frankly i have wondered
if it might be an adaptation of sorts
but it seems clear that it has a
maladaptive component
the component being again for
fans of this podcast who've been through
the telomere explanation multiple times
if you look at the tissues of the body
you will find a very
nifty correlation between tissues that
tend to fail and tissues that don't tend
to get cancer
right so you never hear of anybody who's
got heart cancer to the extent that
you've heard of heart cancer it's
actually
cancer of the pericardium around the
heart and the heart itself
doesn't seem to get cancer almost ever i
can't say never but
almost never and it is prone to failure
right
we've all heard of people dying from
heart failure right that's a
common failure the eye is another place
where cancer is not impossible but it's
very very rare
and so the point is the reproductive
capacity of those tissues
is um therefore limited and that
limitation
results in senescence showing up in the
eyes um
in a readily measurable way but the
middle-aged presbyopia is a
as i understand it we might have it
wrong um but is it about
it's about the extrinsic eye muscles
losing the
rapid ability to change focus so that
they can still do it but it just takes
longer that's that's at least the story
that i've been told by several eye
doctors so it's not the eye tissue it's
the muscle tissue
wow but even so even a muscles
don't tend to get cancer either um
the that's interesting yeah it is
interesting
that's right isn't it um the
slowing down is a senescent effect right
i mean i think that gets us there
muscles also don't get
cancer yeah yeah so but morning sickness
is the thing i really wanted to caveat
here before we actually
try to address the question um which is
that um
a lot of morning sickness is plenty
adaptive um i don't know what is going
on
with um some women who just have
you know such morning sickness that they
really can't function for their entire
first trimester in some cases their
entire pregnancies like that
i honestly have no idea what that
situation is
but morning sickness is absolutely an
adaptive response
um to okay you're pregnant now you've
got something very very fragile inside
of you the more
you know the earlier it is in pregnancy
the more fragile it is
um that thing that you ate uh isn't
conducive to normal development
um i'm you know i your body i'm going to
make you nauseous
um hopefully so as to tell you don't eat
that thing again
well but here's the problem i suspect
i'm sure this is known and then uh all
of the
hague work and market profit um
but in populations that live
in their ancestral environment i would
imagine there's a lot less morning
sickness by virtue of the fact that the
training mechanism the mechanism that
gets you not to eat the thing that
creates the jeopardy for the fetus
is that much more effective right but
that doesn't mean that when it does show
up you know like like i said if it's you
know all the time like i really i don't
know what is going on in that situation
just like i don't understand why there
seems to be an actual population of
women who are like i just can't
breastfeed like i
that strikes me as just not i cannot
put that together with any model that
makes sense but
so we are moving away from an ancestral
environment and being exposed to more
things and so women who have very
you know occasional morning sickness
it's an adaptive response
100 it's an adaptive response i don't
see how that's a disagreement with what
i had said
yeah no it's not i think that
fits but i think it's distinct from um
[Music]
impacted molars is
just simply bad the manifestation
of morning sickness
is an adaptation that is responding to
a novel situation i i think i think it's
here in the model
but it's what it's present we've got all
the pieces in the puzzle and
i don't know that it's worth sorting
them further so are there any similar
widespread conditions found in nature
i presumably that means non-humans a
similar
widespread probably probably in
domesticated animals
right but they're yeah so i'm not even
sure what we're looking for
certainly cancer is a phenomenon that
you find in
nature um you know
um there so so we're looking for
non-pathologic pathogenic
maladaptive um
yeah they're gonna be some sorts of
birth defects that are found somewhere
in a brood
and result in um
in low fitness yeah maybe we can or
extreme specialists you know who are
like adopt adapted to
you know fish that adapt to a particular
little pool with a particular ph or
salinity or something
and uh you know when when the river
overruns and that pool becomes connected
to something else those things that
we're adaptations
like you know things that were adaptive
can become not adapted as conditions
change but
how about the right trying to fit this
into
okay yeah that's good that's good it's
not good to be the runt of the litter it
is a
programmed response to something in
effect it's the start
on an offspring that if times are good
after
yeah but but again it's not you know
it's not
sometimes the rut will die you know so
it's it's
like that's mom's insurance policy yep
right you've got
you can have a brood of four or you can
have a brood of
five that might become four right uh and
uh
you don't have the ability to predict
what kind of a year it's going to be
and if it's a good year you raised five
kids and if it's a bad year you raised
four kids
so why doesn't it fit though i mean it
seems to me that if morning sickness
is a well i was arguing that i don't
think morning sickness belongs on this
list
impacted molars and near-sightedness
um i mean maybe there is no
maybe there is no list really right like
impacted molars are a response to a
hyper-novel environment
um nearsightedness seems to be a
response to
not entire not always but a lot of it is
early reading
and you know and early close focus and
inside inside life
um far sadness is different especially
if you're talking about um
middle-aged presbyopia yeah
yeah you're right maybe the list isn't
it's there's no list because they
they each have at least one bit flipped
in a different direction yeah
yeah maybe that's that's why we're
struggling with this question i think
okay
that's like a terrible answer writ large
but i think it was actually
yeah yeah yeah okay
uh let's try to do a couple more here
and we get to do two more hours tomorrow
none of these questions though
hello professors what role do you think
history should play in one's scientific
education
i found many contemporary undergrad
textbooks utterly inspire
uninspiring due to lack of context am i
just reading them wrong
well i'm curious what the textbooks were
supposed to be in
if um you know
it makes a big difference you know it's
like if if you're reading
i don't know like there's just a lot of
things where i don't think that history
is necessary but
obviously there's a lot of history you
want to try yeah
um i would say um
first off guns germs and steel
you have to understand this principle um
in order to make sense of
the interaction of human populations
and frankly it saves you from all of the
terrible things that we might
fear are explanatory for um
differential levels of success between
populations so
uh you know my sense is
in part history is studied badly
because it is studied it is predicated
on a wrong idea which is that
um that patterns of history are
in large measure the result of decisions
made by individuals on a battlefield or
you know in a in a governance setting
when in fact there are other processes
in motion so i would say i'm a believer
in
what's called big history and
in some sense i think big history is in
a fight
over territory with traditional history
and probably the closer you get to
modernity
the less true this is right there's a
lot to be said for
um you know the battles between
different factions
in the forming of uh the constitution
for example what were the individuals
thinking about which we can know a
tremendous amount
but okay so i i've read the question
again and
he does specify scientific education
so for instance um you know i think
i think mendeleev and
the creation of the periodic table is is
very useful to be thinking about
when you are learning chemistry the
first time
and history as told through like a
history of science philosophy of science
perspective actually gives you a sense
of how science is done
whereas you know the whatever the
scientific equivalent of the battles
would be
like you know who got tenure where or
like
like the kind of you know the stuff that
we as evolutionary biologists know about
like darwin and wallace
okay true but i'm not sure that that's
necessary
as you're as you're really thinking
deeply about evolution um
but keeping track of the players
and their discoveries and what they
meant and how you know one discovery
could be added to by another is actually
a much more interesting
and i think educational way of learning
about this stuff than just learning a
litany of conclusions
yeah but it's really fraught with um
survivor bias of course as history
always is
well it doesn't have to be i mean that's
part of why i'm saying guns terms of
steel
right right but i mean but you know one
scientific education what if you're not
studying the kind of stuff that guns
germs and steel applies to
i don't think it matters frankly the
point is
you approach history scientifically
and if you do so you discover that
processes that aren't even on the
historical map are dominating okay but
like the question is what role do you
think history should play in one's
scientific education
not what role do you think science
should play on one's history education
it's all the same to you in some ways i
mean
look if you study you studied history
hardly and like you you and i both
studied not very much history right
right
but then the point is then you get to
guns germs and steel and you find out
why it wasn't compelling
because it wasn't true and so my point
is that
is a lesson it is a lesson also for
the sense of how it is that science
progresses
how it is that science progresses is
something that we sometimes capture
and sometimes don't capture and always
think we capture
and the fact is what percentage of
scientists today
are convinced that they are living in a
vibrant age in their field and what
percentage of those fields are actually
vibrant right so somehow
we've got a totally wrong story about
the way science works okay
and so you don't think using
putting the history into the study of
science
will be valuable because much of the
history will be
wrong we'll be told by the victors who
maybe shouldn't have been the victors
right and i'm just trying to establish
what it is that you're arguing pick that
lesson up and then you can say actually
you know if i go back through the
history of
physics or biology or whatever i will
see that there are vibrant periods and
there are doldrums
and that people in the doldrums didn't
know they were living in the doldrums
right so am i living in the doldrums
would be the first question you would
get to and if so
is there something i can do to break out
of the doldrums rather than the fact
that
the doldrums are typically now broken
out of by somebody outside the field
who is free to think the kind of
thoughts that people inside the field
aren't free to think
and so anyway
back to that yep um okay i'm just gonna
find a couple more before we uh before
we sign off
do either of you avoid killing household
pests when you don't have to
if so why um
yep i yeah 100
i will go out of my way to take
creatures that are in the house
and put them outside of the house
even though sometimes if it's a mouse
i believe that the mouse probably has
feelings quite analogous to mine and i
feel
some sort of obligation to do that based
on what i think i know about what's
going on
in the mouse's head if it's a spider
i'm pretty sure that that spider is a
machine and then it does not have
subjective experience
sometimes i see video of spiders that
causes me to wonder about that
conclusion
but i think i do it
a because i think
my humanity suffers if i kill that
animal and just decide
that it is not worthy of my
consideration um
i think i could be wrong about what's
going on in the animal's head in which
case i will have been
a terrible cruel person for no reason
other than i didn't want to be
inconvenienced
i guess um i
i can't imagine killing them i mean like
we for some i don't know why but we seem
to be plagued by hemipterons
uh these it's true bugs right and um
they're just all over the place
and while some hemiference do actually
vector a disease
kissing kissing bugs right those are
hemopeptides right
yeah chagas disease that that's not here
there's no there's nothing that these
hamiptorins are
vectoring so far as we know um but i
wish they wouldn't
show up various places like there was
one just back there right before the
start of the podcast which
you know i scooped up and opened a
window took a screen off i think it did
it once before
they sometimes fly around here i don't
know where they're coming from i wish
they weren't here
we ought to open one up and make sure
it's not a drone
yeah true um
and um yeah i feel
and i so if i feel you know if you feel
that way about spiders and i do too i
don't i don't
like spiders as much as i might i'd like
spiders the least of of all of the
all of the things that we run into in
our house that we didn't invite in
um but i still don't kill them i can't
like i can't i can't imagine
choosing to kill them honestly well but
i mean but we also you know we don't
live in an apartment like
you know we can we can take them outside
and like be free
um go do your thing the other thing
though
is that you know if we take if we take
the tough version of this puzzle
yeah um if we had a
raccoon in our yard
that was creating trouble i needed to be
moved yeah
i'd move it even though i know full well
yes
that if i take that raccoon and i move
it somewhere else
without changing the carrying capacity
of somewhere else it is very likely that
a raccoon probably the one i've
transported will die because it doesn't
know anything about the place so it's at
a disadvantage
and even if it does survive it will
result in some other raccoon starving
yes um so i will do that even though i
know that i'm probably not uh
saving the animal and i i thought you
can't you couldn't bear
to kill a raccoon if i hadn't
do it yes if i had to i could but um but
uh
i don't have to and i do have the sense
of hey what do i know
maybe carrying capacity is down by a bit
and this animal
that didn't do anything wrong and just
started doing what it does in my yard
where i can't have it
that by moving it somewhere else maybe
it gets to live a life and
yeah you know i i don't want to decide
that's not going to happen therefore
you're going to die
that doesn't feel right to me yeah
although you know with something like a
raccoon
even something like a mouse if you
wouldn't not here but um when we lived
in olympia
we lived across the street from part of
the thousand acre campus
that evergreen was and um we would take
mice across the street into the forest
we had a mouse problem in the house and
uh it was exacerbated by our cats rather
than
helped by it they would bring them these
are deer mice yeah these are deer mice
not house mice
miscus right and um so they forced mice
um but they didn't live a quarter mile
away in the forest
and we would take them a quarter mile
away and the first door and eight the
mile but like we would take them
away from certainly if they were
territorial anything like their
territory but also their home range
and not only add them to presumably
a population that was already full of
perimiscus but also leave them you know
out of sorts and like where did i just
land
um but we did that rather than killing
them
yep although i mean the place where this
really gets me is every so often
i will come across a injured animal
that isn't going to live and i will kill
them and i hate it it's terrible
i really dislike it um but it is the
right thing to do
yeah um
one last question does having kids
increase life satisfaction
um having kids
destroys your life and then he's still
in there you know
and then it makes a better one
um so it changes it changes who you are
it changes what you're about i mean it
should
if it doesn't that's a problem right um
but i would say yeah
you know it it does create a kind of
meaning
that you may be able to cobble together
from other things
but it's not a slam dunk that you will
whereas kids
uh that the meaning is very very clear
and
right away so yeah i think it does and
it's
it's unlike anything else and you know
neither of us proselytize
for parenthood never have um but
uh it's extraordinary and unparalleled
yeah i would say
um if you shouldn't have kids
don't if you should have kids then
definitely do it
um in spite of the fact that you're a
font of useful knowledge today
no i think this is there's somebody out
there who is
who needs to hear this okay so say it
again and and clarify
shouldn't have kids don't right it's not
like oh my god you need to have kids in
order to be a complete human being
and even though you think you shouldn't
have them you should right if you feel
like no i shouldn't have kids
don't have them if you think the world
sucks and i'm not sure i want to bring
kids into it
have them just have them
the fact is the world sucks i'm not
sorry to be here though
right and that's the way most people
feel about it
and the point is there is meaning to be
had it's not simple your kids will be a
bit [ __ ] up
um you can't avoid it i mean that's
that's modernity but
um the opportunity
to be a person on this marvelous planet
it
may be getting less marvelous but it's
still pretty freaking amazing is
uh fantastic not to be missed and
if you're inclined to bring people into
the world don't overthink it
i have them and uh you know raise them
right
wonderful all right beautiful answer
thank you i think we have reached the
end here join
us tomorrow if you want on our patreon
private q a
and uh next week saturday and sunday for
brett's
private conversations on his patreon
email darkhorse.moderator gmail.com with
questions
comments if you feel like it what else
uh
oh you got something from you got an
answer on
congratulations to paul harvey
for winning the clubhouse invite you
will find it in your text messages
see you on there and wear a helmet
[Music]
you could food love the people in your
life and get outside
and we will see you next week all right
be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you